okay we've got a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's someone who believes i am a
hypocrite that's nothing new let's take
a listen hey David
in the March night show it seemed like
you were talking about how labels are
not terribly useful in political
discussions and that you would rather
talk to somebody about their beliefs
against yours or ideas against yours
Frank but when you had David Rubin on it
seemed that you were pretty dead set on
establishing what classical liberal
shouldn't mean and you kind of seem to
focus a lot on the label at that point
so I wondered if there would be there
and what you might think thank you yeah
well no wait so that's exactly right I
had Dave Rubin on and I said let's
forget about the label of classical
liberalism for a second what are the
policy positions and the ideas and the
principles that are important to you so
I think I did exactly what I told that
caller last week we should be doing
which is fine pick whatever label you
want but let's figure out how that is
defined and what your political
positions are so I think maybe it's an
attempt to call me a hypocrite which is
not really an example of me being a
Fikret and there are plenty of examples
of me being a hypocrite you should talk
to uh talk to people in my personal life
but at least as far as this goes I don't
think there is any any evidence of
hypocrisy you're being condescending to
the voicemail caller we got a live call
about that last week I hope you're not
being that way not at all I think that
they're just wrong I think they're
flat-out wrong and I'm willing to say it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get access to the bonus show
become a member
become a patron both great ways to get
access and we'll speak to you then